should we talk about the whistleblower
from Apple or what because we got a
bunch of other stories too
yeah let's keep it moving sure so the
reason I thought this story was was was
it was uh was this you know the reason
why I thought there's a store there's
something way to absolutely talk about
is because we had just done a big
segment where I was like they're not
spying on you they're not listening
they're just predicting your behavior
right and now we have this guy is a
whistleblower slamming Apple for
wiretapping entire populations oh really
were yeah really we're listening you
know I should clarify too because I was
I was I think I think I was absolutely
inaccurate and phrasing everything I was
saying about the spine okay they are
spying on you and I think I was to
clarify they know exactly what you're
gonna do a lot of the ads you see are
not because they're spying on you but
because they predict your behavior
mm-hmm they also do spy on you're also
spying on you yeah so there's a there's
a bunch of stories about like the Amazon
device whose name I will not say because
it'll start talking yeah I recorded a
conversation and apparently law
enforcement wanted access to the
recording mm-hmm and Amazon was like no
and people were like wait a minute
why is there a recording of this yeah so
like someone got murdered yes it's
always recording and you try to explain
to people how do you think it knows when
you say it's name because it's listening
to you and so what people don't
understand about how these devices work
as a Siri in this story it used to be
very early on it would be like save say
this phrase three times and then it
would try and create a profile for you
saying it okay it never works yeah cuz
it'll be like you know you the phrase
will be like you know computer activator
something right and then one day you're
like tired you go a computer activate it
won't recognize you because when you
first set you're like computer activate
and because you say differently won't
work so the way they do it now is the
microphones are on when you talk it it's
constantly sending what you say to a
company to trim to turn that the text in
the speech and a text until it gets the
command and then activates right it's
really funny with without with like the
the Amazon device there's a whole bunch
of words that you can say that are not
its name that activate it right so long
as it they have the same vowels in the
same order okay so it's like
why it frequently turns on an accident
because it hears something close enough
and but let's let's see what's going on
a former Apple contractor revealed the
firm's grading project last year
Thomas Lee Boniek worked under AC
reading project that gathered snippets
of audio in order to improve the smart
assistants accuracy last year la banach
revealed the Guardian that while working
for Apple he heard private and sometimes
intimate recordings including medical
discussions criminal activity sex and
official business talks the
whistleblower had initially remained
anonymous but has revealed himself in a
protest against the lack of action taken
against Apple for violating fundamental
human rights and he has done so with an
open letter to European privacy
regulators stating his concerns I just
had a horrifying thought oh no what
what if Alex Jones was right about
everything everything everything that's
a bold statement though you heard about
the frogs he said a lot of things well
it's a lot of things wait what about the
Frog YouTube's finger over the band
button can read duck oh oh the frogs
yeah frogs gay man yeah that actually
happened atrazine okay so as you seen in
the water makes frogs less likely to
reproduce okay
well it's it's it's a it's a complicated
story it is complicated
oh is it complicated and I think I think
it has been partially debunked but there
were initial studies showing that
atrazine was mutating the endocrine
systems of frogs
so they would have like their ovaries
would become testes has his ovaries or
hybridize making him sterile or
something okay and so you know Jones in
it in his entertaining rage yells
they're turning the frickin frogs gay
you know I am kidding about him being
right about everything
but the point I'm trying to make in
saying that is right now we are under
what's essentially a nationwide lockdown
you know people are being arrested for
organizing protests the first women is
gone New York says you can't protest
sorry
shut up meanwhile people in New York
City are jumping jumping on top of cars
and twerking and simulating sex not
exaggerating there's photos and videos
popping up this stuff and the cops don't
do anything about it
so we're literally watching everything
fall apart big business is taking over
yeah it's like they want all the
businesses to close it's like part of
their agenda it feels like I I'm not I'm
not implying everything's intentional
but I'm just saying like all of these
horrible government overreach things are
happening no one's doing anything
anything about it yeah
Apple is spong and everything you say
you're tracking every move you make boy
it really feels like all of these novels
just merged into one and then just
happened overnight it was like what
three months ago three months ago life
was normal
yeah we saw movies yeah complained about
Trump all day though they've tried to
impeach him you know now it's like this
now they complain about Trump but
they've also locked us in our homes
you can't escape them complaining about
Trump and they still hit it on Trump
like it's his fault still it's like well
that is like telling everyone we want it
open like well let's open it up but
there's but there's a disease right so
it's like so okay hold on we got a
disease pandemic we got big tech spying
on us social media censorship and
thought you know thought manipulation
mm-hmm algorithmic manipulation to
control people can see in here you so
you got the government like on top of
that yeah I think we hit everything you
know we got brave new world 1984 that
little bit of animal farm if you go back
a couple decades I guess huh yeah yeah
we did it is that what that was at the
goal that's that's that's a joke I'm
making with Jones though like yeah I'm
not saying that they're their map of
what was what's gonna happen was correct
in terms of like who's responsible but
we're going to end up now quarantined
mandatory government injections Locke
you know shut your business down still
can't believe it's real
I mean but yeah but we could argue just
Dersch which is and not right you know
what happens after this all over there's
there some estimates say 40 percent of
businesses will never reopen you know
and there's all there's a study from
Axio saying 100,000 businesses will have
already have already permanently
shuttered Wow those people gonna go work
for big corporate chains afterwards it's
the only truth they have yep New York
you know yeah it's real a bit more about
this year fella he says there's not much
vetting of who works there and the
amount of data that were free to look
through seems quite broad
it wouldn't be difficult to identify the
person that you're listening to
especially with accidental triggers
addresses names and so on the letter
which LeBlanc sent labonte ik sent to
all European data protection regulator
states it is worrying that Apple and
undoubtedly not just Apple keeps
ignoring and violating fundamental
rights and continues their massive
collection of data
I am extremely concerned that big tech
companies are basically wiretapping
entire populations
despite European citizens being told the
EU as one of the strongest data
protections law dat oppression laws in
the world passing a law is not good
enough it needs to be enforced upon
privacy offenders Lebon eyx held a sub
contractor subcontractor position at
Apple's Cork offices where he listened
to snippets in both English and French
until resigning in 2019 they do operate
on a moral and legal gray area he told
the Guardian at the time and they have
been doing this for years on a massive
scale they should be called out in every
possible way
he continued to say that he would listen
to thousands of recordings every day and
have a range of Apple devices including
iPhones Apple watches and iPads any
device that included Siri here's a
question are you are you always
listening I only listen when you're
talking to me aren't you always talking
to her if you're asking her saying her
name yeah you she thinks you're always
talking to her that's the loophole there
you go this is actually a really
hilarious story you know what I'm also
in the vert I'm like I'm some on the
vert I'm so close to myself I find up a
hot bath fight some candles just laying
back and just you know no it's just
relaxing lower the blow of the blood
temperature the the the blood pressure a
little bit like here's a guy who a year
ago said excuse me um these big tech
companies are violating our rights Shh
they did nothing about it then nothing
nothing that's I don't know it's not
really surprising it's like they can pay
to all these big companies they're just
paying the appropriate people to just
continue on doing what they're doing
it's like what is the the average
person's supposed to do what can they do
what can we do you know what is what is
it I said anything we would be banned
instantly the stream would be cut off
exactly that's what I'm saying blue is
on the horizon yeah that's what I feel
it you feel like there's nothing you can
do
you you you've got people listening to
you bang your your significant other
yeah what he's saying it's messed up
yeah well intentionally listening yep
and then tracking it for improving it oh
my gosh
I I don't I don't I don't at this point
you know I wonder how much stress the
people can take you know it's
interesting because with the boogaloos
of the past we haven't had the internet
and mass spying and the security
apparatus of the state hasn't been this
strong right now it's insanely strong
yeah but we do we do have a lot of areas
the police refusing to enforce these
these these rules yeah in certain states
I shouldn't call them rule just cool
decree yeah yep so it's only a matter of
time I guess before there's lines drawn
between the mindless drones like New
York City cops I think are the worst
they really don't care about the
Constitution yeah they really don't
there's small small small town cops
sheriffs and local departments seem to
yeah I'm surprised about the Belmar
Police Department where they're doing
this and I have I have no respect for
these mindless drones the you know I
guess somebody's hosting with the gym
said they're being forced to do it
that's just absolutely not true forced
to evaluate the Constitution was it
doesn't make sense yeah look you gotta
make a choice man if someone tells you
to break the law and you do it you're
responsible at the person I mean you
could argue the person who told you to
do it is responsible as well yeah well
it I don't know man I guess people are
trying to keep defending it until we run
out of food that's what's really about
once the food goes then it doesn't
matter what they say people are gonna
riot yeah yeah so maybe there won't be
though maybe they know that maybe
they're just like we'll just send food
to your house I don't know it's because
people need more than they need purpose
and now that people have none they're
getting antsy and they want to get back
to work yeah
part of me feels like it's gonna blow
over right there slowly reopening things
yeah we keep saying that though and then
the day goes by and something else
happens proves us wrong
yeah you know I want to believe it too I
really want to you know I I want to be
happy and jolly and live live and I want
everyone to feel happy and satisfied in
their life you know I want that but it
there's people out here that feel like
that doesn't matter what you think we're
gonna do what we think is best for
everyone and you're gonna you're gonna
sit and take it they're burning down
their own cities they're burning down
their own states you know I wrote that
song find yourself like five years ago
and man listening to the lyrics reading
the lyrics like singing and I'm like man
it is so relevant nowaday now than ever
before it's insane what's it about it's
about the like people taking control and
telling you what to believe and what you
believe is wrong and what they say goes
and are you are you just gonna sit there
and swallow it and take it or are you
gonna stand up and for your rights you
know oh that sounds like dangerous
thinking Adam let's just stick to your
working and I don't think I'm gonna be
the one who starts it they're they're
doing it to themselves in many states
life has remained the same yeah like
people who have locally sourced goods
yeah probably I've noticed a whole lot
yeah it's the big cities that are the
most heavily impacted you know it's also
the big of the big cities where the
people mostly want to stay lockdown I
think it's because these are you know
you've seen the Hunger Games I have you
have the Capitol and like everyone the
Capitol is like wearing weird clothes
and they eat too much and then drink it
but cat vomit and then keep eating again
yeah yeah that's how like gluttonous
they are those are the cities it really
is these are people who the example I
like to give is the bridges mm-hmm
living in New York you've got all these
bridges just there yeah never watch them
be built different for granted never did
any work for them never built them look
paid for it or anything just there
I don't got to think twice I got to pay
anything yeah it's just there for me
and so all of these people live in a
world where they think things should
just be there for them and that's where
they're at now they're like okay we're
not working I mean man you know what so
many jobs in New York are not real jobs
I agree like you know like what's a good
example of a fake job
BuzzFeed writer okay yeah that's a fake
job yeah for sure
or like a club promoter yeah sure it's a
job but no that's a real job okay that's
a real job sure letting letting people
know about you know sell the libations
and dancing and relaxation sure that's a
real service for somebody okay people
people need to really you know a lot of
some steam and yeah yeah a fake job is
like scouring the Internet to complain
about what was that what was that
article we saw the other day Ivanka
Trump saying the word taken and then
writing 500 words about how it's all
trite and dangerous yeah that is not a
real job okay I can agree with you that
so now that these people are no longer
working their fake jobs they still think
things should just be given to them so
they're sitting in their cubicle
apartments demanding the government pay
them
I had only last so long until the
government says no you know meanwhile
the people who live you know in the
middle of nowhere who I've already we
when we were driving in LA mm-hmm
we stopped in this town I think was in
Arizona I came by the name of it no
social distancing no lockdown fast food
chains were open it was a very small
town by the way and I went in you know
to get stuff I had my mask but I was
like no but he's wearing a mask nobody
cares so I grabbed some coffees you know
I grabbed you know Sam some and I was
paying for it and I said no nobody's
wearing a mask no lockdown and the lady
what laughing she goes no we don't care
about none of that and I was like really
is you're not you're not worried about
getting sick and it's like nope don't
care and I was like what about you know
supply chain stuff it was oh we're all
Preppers I started laughing I'm really
she's like yeah the only thing we're
worried about is when the power goes out
and I was it happened a lot just happens
yeah so we all have generators and I was
like okay yeah yeah they did not care
yes that's self-reliance because they
have a town where they're like we know
where our foods at she was funny this
lady told me she's like went out
everything she's like everything went
down my husband turns to me and says do
you think we have enough toilet paper
and it's hard
fingernails like we're Preppers she's
like we've got like three months worth
yeah and she laughed about like why
would you even ask I thought that was
hilarious
was funny yeah so so what happens to
these cities like they're just decaying
yeah I mean if the food chain really
does get disrupted cities can't really
exist anymore because it can't support
that many people farmers that already
have farms that know their neighbors
that have trade systems that will be
naturally built up those are that's
gonna be what's gonna survive
you know big cities people are just
gonna riot and then leave to go find you
know land where there is food is this
like a natural occurrence for like an
injury where it's it's it's almost it's
gonna purge the left I don't mean purge
in like and their lives I mean it's
going to the ideology is going to be
crushed and this we've already seen
we've already talked about this like
social justice stuff has been really
really pushed aside yeah and and like I
was saying earlier the culture war has
now become about lockdown versus you
know opening up mm-hmm
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you